Hi
My name is Chris Gagné and I'm an Agile coach
Today, I will talk about the Definition of Done
The Definition of Done is a documented team agreement
It defines the conditions that must be met
For a potentially shippable product to be considered
Done as in done
It's how we know that we did the thing right
Meaning we built in the correct level of quality into the product
These are different from the acceptance criteria which are written by the product owner
And help us know that we did the right thing
Creating and following the Definition of Done diligently
Can easily double the speed of an Agile team
Lean practitioners will tell you that in the long run
Quality is free!
Because if you don't build a quality product in the short run
You're going to pay for it in the long run due to increased technical debt
The slow pace of manual testing
And production bugs
Having lots of hidden undone work in your product
Will make releasing your feature to customers
Difficult and risky
Scrum doesn't talk about this much detail
But many less mature teams use two sets of Definition of Done
One is targeted at what you will consider done
For a single product increment that you are bundling into a release
The other is the Definition of Done for that entire release
Over time you want to improve your practices
Environment
And team structure
So that you can potentially release any given product increment at any time
So what should you include in your Definition of Done?
Well at a minimum, you're going to want your work to be
Code complete
Unit, integration, and performance tested
You want to have just enough documentation
No new bugs or technical debt
And lastly accepted by the product owner who is meeting the acceptance criteria
I suggest spending an hour as a team to review sample Definitions of Done
And craft your own
Then review your Definition of Done periodically, so that it fits your team's retrospectives
At the beginning, your Definition of Done may have just a few items
And as your team
And automation matures
Expand your Definition of Done
To include more scope